It would be good if when I get to
the end of my story, I could start over.
So that I can see all the different
possibilities for the tigers fate.
Here's what that would look like.
Where in the storyboard,
should we put the start over button?
We could drag separate buttons into
each of the end points in Storyboard.
But we need to consider this,
what class is the object that
would receive these actions?
If we look in the Identity Inspector,
we see that the View Controller for
each story node is a UIViewController.
We can't add an action method directly
to a Stock UIViewController class.
The name of the subclass we're
using is MYOAViewController,
as you can see here in
the project navigator.
So, we'll go back to the Identity
Inspector, and we'll add that class name
so that we can programmatically
add a button to each story node.
By the way,
a detailed review of these steps will be
provided in the next part of the lesson.
Okay.
Let's see about adding that
button in code.
Every View Controller has a property
called a Navigation Item.
This item can be used to
control the title and buttons.
Here in the Navigation Item
documentation,
you can see that it has
a right bar button item.
With these two lines of code,
we can add the right bar button item in
the viewDidLoad method and
specify the title, start over.
Now, we'll run it and see where we are.
Well, there's our button, but
naturally it doesn't lead anywhere
because we haven't set the target yet.